you're keeping us up to date with the i
mean the huge amount the
the shifting tectonic plates within the
conservative party and uh we're seeing
here and this tells us quite a lot here
we're seeing within the cabinet in
itself that uh a new health secretary
has been appointed yes steve barkley so
i think this most importantly shows that
the prime minister is carrying on and
we're seeing a sort of mini reshuffle
here going on he's not been appointed
the health secretary who will be the
next chancellor that remains to be seen
we've seen um nadim zahawi going in to
education the education secretary
a close ally of the prime ministers and
there has been there has been
speculation um
not based on anything in particular from
what i understand that he could be
another
person who could potentially one of the
big names that could potentially break
ranks um but
he um there's uh he has been seen there
you go going into number 10. um just
just before we hit the top of the hour
um
how many
junior ranks have gone we know about the
two cabinet ministers you've been
keeping a yes tally some big names um on
the junior ranks jonathan gullis
one of the biggest cheerleaders for the
prime minister bim afulami i mean he's
not a junior rank he's vice chair of the
party but he's a sort of younger
generation coming up nicola richards um
a pps sachi bhati a pbs in the treasury
um and some pretty extraordinary letters
of resignation nicola richards i'm
saying that party is currently
unrecognizable so
interesting times but of course the two
big names health secretary and the
chancellor certainly are interesting
times that ali must end up there thank
you very much indeed